when Bob and I started thinking about
this series of the first among the first
names we thought of immediately was
today's speaker and he was an
immediately logical choice for talking
about interactive and progressive and
productive interactions between
philosophy and and the sciences
Maxwell Bennett was born and educated in
Melbourne and has been a faculty member
at the department of physiology at the
University of Sydney for all of his
postgraduate career and he is the but
University chair and in in Physiology
and the director of if I correct this
not in here the brain studies Institute
indeed Maxwell's interest in
neuroscience and philosophy go back to
his to his roots he was an undergrad
studying in engineering and in physics
but with a great interest in philosophy
and he as a result a decision early on
in his education that he the productive
way to study consciousness and and and
and and humans was through neuroscience
he then by his account sort of wandered
into into into neurobiology starting
immediately as an undergraduate just
finishing his engineering degree he did
some early and revolutionary discoveries
experiments on the discovery of unusual
synapses in the autonomic nervous system
in the viscera and by applying his
electrical engineering know-how to
tissues and questions that were at the
periphery of other people's interests he
made as a young man tremendously
important contributions that have that
have established his career on the
physiology of the synapse in
particularly the interaction of synapses
with muscles etc of course max describes
this as an accident but it's a perfect
example of the
the way in which the outsiders with a
new toolbox who are uninhibited by the
dogma within the field actually can make
revolutionary contributions max showed
that the physiology of these autonomic
nerves were quite distinct and and and
decades later was able establish that
this novel no transmitter involvement
Yves was ATP max went on to make more
revolutionary discoveries in responsive
neurons to injury synapse formation the
interaction of synapses with muscle
fibers and the role of non-college genic
synapses in brain and and the modulation
of in pain sorry and the modulation of
the immune system now beginning in the
1990s max began to return to his
original interest in philosophy that
complemented his ongoing neuroscience
work and since 1998 he has published
seven books some with his collaborator
Oxford philosopher Peter hacker and they
include the idea of consciousness the
history of the synapse philosophical
foundations of neuroscience with with
Peter hacker history of cognitive
neuroscience again with with Peter
Packer and most recently in 2013 of
Virginia Woolf and neuropsychiatry he
tells me for his next book that he is
interested in returning to one of his
favorite philosophers Spinoza and I
think that that that project is ongoing
of course max is the recipient of
numerous awards and and prizes and I
won't get into all they all of those but
today he will deliver the first of a
pair of talks on the history of mind
tomorrow here at the Whitney Humanities
Center at one o'clock he will continue
with a companion lecture on the history
of consciousness so please join me in
welcoming Maxwell Bennett
we human beings have a corporal body and
a range of psychological capacities or
powers remembering feeling deceiving
thinking etc the basis of my
presentation is to look at the history
of the relationship between this
corporal structure and these
psychological powers much to my surprise
I believe that the story begins 5,000
years ago where really the paradigm for
our thinking about this subject in the
subsequent periods which laid down by
the Egyptians not the boy or too much
because it's actually quite excited when
you get into it what the Egyptians
believed is indicated here in this
diagram here is the shadow or the shoot
which the Egyptians thought was actually
a live process much the same as probably
a few thousand years earlier the shamans
of thought when we go to sleep we dream
and we dream sometimes about ourselves
sometimes about dearly beloved ones that
have passed on sometimes about our
enemies but these dreams are full of
shadowy figures including ourselves we
can identify people sometimes in the
dreams as a consequence of the
silhouette the shape of the person in
the dream but really in the context of
shamanism in the context of the way the
Egyptians thought about the dreams they
thought that the shadow that they cast
on the ground was probably much the same
as the kinds of figures they met in
their dreams including themselves so the
shoot or shadow was a very real object
for them both when they were asleep and
when they are awake but it had no
personality it was you know
since a walking kind of toes individual
so we could not in any way attribute to
that the idea of immortality or
something of that kind but in addition
to the shoot and the most important
element in the theology of Egyptians was
the bar this incongruous figure of a
bird with wings but with a human head
and what this is really a metaphor for
is the fact that when you die you are
judged and your judgement is on the
basis of the weight of your heart it was
the weight of the heart was measured
against a feather so it had to be a
pretty light heart and of course since
this was a religious idea the extent to
which the weight of your heart indicated
you'd lived a good life was really on
the basis of how much money you'd paid
to the priests of the temple so that if
you had a very light heart and you got
through this process then you'd coughed
up quite a lot of money problem so you
then got through to a stage in the
afterlife with you were the bar and the
bar had a very good time because most of
the day it flew off to the area where
one had lived when Mum was alive and
your part took in all the gossip and
caring zhan of the society and of the
family that you loved and then in the
evening you had to come back to the
region of the tomb and you came back to
the ridge in the tomb because as we all
know in order to proceed through the day
we need some kind of energy we need to
be vital in some way and just the same
as we do the Egyptians believed that we
needed food and so this food gave us
energy or the car as the Egyptians
thought it and so the bird had to come
back to the to him because in general
that's where the food was to be found
now of course the food was presented
around the tomb in a metaphorical sense
I mean wine was there and matters of
that kind left but people who loved us
but this was just a symbol of the fact
that one had to return to the tomb in
order to receive the energy of the car
so the by
on the car were essential parts of the
story now when you first hear about this
in the book of the Dead
you kind of think well this is a kind of
extrange kind of fairy tale but the
following table sets out the succeeding
5,000 years of our considerations of the
relationship between the mind the
Corporal and other matters why do I
suddenly introduce the word mind it's to
actually alert you to the fact that the
way we use the word mind these days is
really just another way of talking about
our psychological powers we say mind
your step deceive or look where you're
going
we say keep that in mind remember that
or we say mind what you're say made me
think about before you actually sign it
so in common parlance now the word mind
has come to mean these kinds of
psychological powers so when I ask the
question what is the relationship
between psychological powers and our
corporeal body in a sense I'm asking
that what is the relationship between
our mind and our corporeal body now to
some extent I think the way the
Egyptians thought about this and is
indicated here shows you the power of
their thinking I'm afraid to say you'll
have to read something which is kind of
like an academic title but what we have
here is their why in which the actual
Egyptians thought around about 3000 BC
we have the shoes or the shadow which is
a spirit type substance if you like but
which was unrelated to our personality
but had something to do with and it's
rather the same way as the shaman them
still practice their ideas about the
afterlife but as I've just put emphasis
on the bar namely the head the head of
the bird here which did have your
individuality it did have your
personality as I think I've exemplified
in my little homologue about that and
then the car is the force or the
nutrient if you like that's necessary to
keep the bar going all the time what I
didn't refer to explicitly with the gym
of a heart which is wired up at the time
of judgment
the harm was related to our notions
which is something which comes naturally
to us because we're excited and
what-have-you we feel quite often our
heart beating more vibrantly now these
notions of separation of three elements
here what we would regard the most
important very the individuality the
baha but also up here emotions and down
here or intentions and down here the
life force is a continuing tripartite
division we find in the next fire of
3,000 years at least so when we come
through to the next major period here
we're really dealing at this time here
with Homer and what we have with Homer
is a continuation of this idea of a
spirit lacking any intended
individuality at all but continuing on
now though it's called something which
we're all familiar with not a shoot like
a cycle and so the psyche which was just
a renaming in a sense of the shoot of
the Egyptians and now we're dealing with
eight century BC and not 3,000 but it's
also really naming here of the seat of
our body of the emotions and are the
intentions by calling it thymus rather
than calling up the June and then when
we come to reasoning or individuality in
this case we have another work which we
are committed with and that is announced
I don't think that person's got much
announced they're not very intelligent
unfortunately Homer didn't take on the
fact that we need nutrient and we need
energy in order to continue throughout
the day but he did resurrect if you like
for reasons which I think we can follow
now historically these ideas the
Egyptians some nearly 2,000 years after
they originally brought into practice
now we come into the classical Greek
period where those giants Plato and
Aristotle occurred now Plato took these
ideas and rejuvenated them about 300
years after her
but with the following huge difference
because with Homer the psyche and the
tireless and annouce all died at our
corporal death when we lost the Corporal
we lost a lot that certainly didn't
happen with the Egyptians as I've
stressed and with Plato it didn't happen
either so Plato resurrected the concept
that this was immortal and furthermore
he resurrected the concept that we
needed something in the way of a
nutritive activity like the car but the
Egyptians mouse or noose if you like is
translated as the mind yeah and so the
mind or the noose is at this time
associated with reasoning with thinking
capacities of your life and very closely
associated with our personality but yeah
with the psyche the tireless the noose
amid paralleling the Egyptian show these
are now immortal but aware with
Egyptians and like they were not with
Homer at all Plato had the one of the
worst experiences that any academic can
have they had a student who was cleverer
than himself and that student was
Aristotle of course I hate to say it but
my hero so I give my story away
Aristotle pointed out to his master that
this system couldn't work it couldn't
work because you cannot take any mortal
spiritus substance and related to a
corporeal physical body with extension
how do you join them together
what sort of bridge could you use what
kind of bridging is substance the whole
system won't work Aristotle escaped this
dilemma by saying something which is
resurrected only 60 years ago by lunatic
and star matters that our psychological
capacities and our cluding our
rationality and thinking and also our
nutritive powers these were not a
substance at all they were capacities or
powers and you don't have to have a
bridging problem then
confronted you when you're trying to
relate capacitors to the corporeal body
via Skype that problem if your life by
introducing this way of looking at the
whole matter
now this preeminent genius not only as
Charles Darwin says in the first page of
the origin of the thesis the greatest
biologist that ever lived but he also
was extremely interested in physiology
and so had been asked himself having set
out this system here and to ask himself
well amongst other things how do we move
the corporeal body what is the mechanism
to its movement and he said well the
best way of considering this since it's
such an extraordinary thing to be able
to locomote round the place that he
envisage the fact that the whole of our
atmosphere reaching out to the Stars was
actually contained and C fused by
something which we until recent times
were still using namely that it was a
kind of a plenum it was a kind of a
substance which we could breathe in over
time and when we breathed it in
something from the Stars it was able to
be taken into the lungs taken to the
heart where it became what he called
vital Enuma and the vital numa inside
the heart now was transferred down
through the blood vessels to the muscles
and it was blood vessels which moved
muscles nerves were not known at stage
it was the blood vessels that moved the
muscles so this was one important kind
of physiological activity opened up how
does the corporeal body move what is the
mechanism by which this occurs the other
problem which he opened up and one which
has been figuring a great deal in the
neuroscientist in the last twenty years
was this when I look at you are gently
sitting in the second row here as he's
wearing a blue jumper and he's falling
asleep is on total merger with his head
down like that and he's yawning
and he's turning to his right and he's
itching himself
here how is it that I take this in as a
synoptic figure someone with this color
this shape moving in this world making
these sounds so he said there must be
somewhere in the body what he called the
census communis that is the common sense
where the five senses that we have
smelled and perception that is
observation hearing touch these sorts of
things where these five senses are
brought together so we have a synoptic
view of and for a long long time
including recent times the concept of
the census communis and where it should
be and if there is such a concept at all
has dominated some parts of neuroscience
so that was not by any means an
irrelevant way of thinking about the
action of these psychological capacities
having to be brought together in the
census communis the biggest shake-up of
his whole theory going back to the
egyptians occurred as you all know in
the 17th century as due to Descartes
dark heart shook the whole thing in a
dramatic way and I'm afraid to say that
nearly all of you still live under the
shadow of Descartes thought I'll hold
that until tomorrow because dycar brings
in the idea of consciousness which are
not going to touch on to die but what I
am going to touch on today is the fact
that following this period where
Aristotle had developed these skins
there was no major movement about this
question of relating the psychological
to the Corporal until about the first
century I do and that was due to one of
the greatest medical figures in history
that was due to Guilin in Rome
a Greek what Galen was able to do was
something that I think neuroscientists
and neurologists have been doing ever
since he's got his hand on some cadavers
the right material for researching this
type and he also was able to examine
people who were still alive who had had
some very severe injuries
and he had a lot of them to examine
because he put his tent up just outside
the Coliseum and as the gladiators came
out with their various terrible wounds
some of them did he immediately grabbed
them I made a very close examination of
what kind of lesions they had and to
what extent that had changed their
behavior now he discovered something
which is quite profound because what
Aristotle had said well here in the
fourth century BC is that he thought
really as another part of his physiology
argument that when we perceived the
world we'd be actually need an organ to
sustain our capacity to see things and
that all of them was most likely the
heart and so medicine was practiced
really over their peers in nearly 400
years on the basis but the heart has to
be in good condition for you to be able
to pursue Galla put all that to rest
because he showed that in any of these
glided gladiators if I had an injury to
the heart they just drop dead but of a
head injuries of a certain kind of a
head then they might have lost for
example sight or they might have lost
for example being able to have the
capacity to hear they would have lost
some of them accepted the capacities
furthermore they personalities might of
change that they don't bring below to
the frontal lobes so he was able to show
and argue that it wasn't the heart that
you needed for perception that you
needed the head as the organ that was
required for you as a human being to
perceive the world
well the question which immediately came
up then is well what happens to the
physiology of Aristotle about this this
this vital Newman business that
breathing in the ether which was the
plenum that Aristotle 9be aether turning
out at the whole of the universe you
breathe in the ether goes into your
lungs to your heart becomes a vital numa
blood disks well if the heart's not
important what's going on and one guy
one picked up on force what must be
going on as you breathe in the ether
goes into your heart becomes vital humor
and then it's pumped up into the head
where it becomes
because the socket had been brought in
already by Plato so we have a psychic
hero in the head as the core of our
capacity to be able to move and organize
our limbs because we now knew about
nerves so nerves lift the head taking
the psychic numa to the muscles and we
could now move our muscles now that
might sound to be academic using the
usual pejorative sense as nonsense or
irrelevant but it isn't as I will touch
on a little while so our psychological
capacities are somehow related to our
heads well there's a lot of stuff in the
head and what part of the head is
relevant was not really tricked out by
Gaia was tricked out some 300 years
later around about the beginning of the
fourth century I did she kicked out by
Bishop nemesis Bishop nemesis didn't do
any experiments which was a very unwise
than its do what he argued was that you
could work out which part of a head was
involved by simply looking at for
example the open skull of a donkey if
you open up the skull and look at a doc
is hid that is what we've been now
called the cortex
it has creations of one kind another
what we call garay on sulky and they
look exactly the same as what we see
when we open up the skull of a human
being so that cannot have anything to do
with our psychological capacities
because clearly we are clever and we
have lots of other attributes but
doctors don't have so he hit on the idea
of don't forget this is just at the
beginning around about 300 AD this is a
time when he said in place the doctrine
which is then called the ventricular
doctrine that is it is the fluid-filled
part of the brain ventricles which are
responsible for our psychological
ability of thinking remembering
receiving and what handler medicine was
then practiced there nearly 1500 years
on the basis of the fact that there's
something had gone wrong with the fluid
filled ventricle the middle
for example you would lose your memory
if something had gone wrong with the
fluid filled ventricle up here you would
lose your rationality if something had
gone wrong with the fluid his ventricle
down here then your capacity for
perception would be in trouble is shown
here so here is a classical medical
diagram at the time the fluid filled
ventricle is very beautifully designed
here something on which and these days
we spend a lot of our time lying to the
neocortex given this kind of filigree
activity as the walls of the ventricle
but the cortex of the brain was just
there to be the wall of the ventricles
because it was in the ventricles where
all the action was it was only about
this time after this drawing was made
around about the distant century now
that the question not only of where our
psychological capacities are in terms of
our leading and Orban to sustain them
but also a return to the question of
where is the census communities and that
genius Leonardo da Vinci reckon he'd
Goddard because he made a drawing which
I've actually seen and held which is now
in Windsor Castle he made a diagram of
where the census commuters which I've
described you previously is in the brain
and it's just here what you've got here
is some drawings of Leonardo and in
Latin he of course written backwards in
his mirror handwriting what you've got
where the vertical line here meets the
horizontal line right there he said is
the census communis unfortunately he
didn't leave with us a very good
argument as to why that's where the
census communities he didn't tell us why
he bridged that at all and he's not
quoted often in the literature as having
found the census community we now go on
to that magic century of genius from the
greatest century of genius since the
century Athens and that is the 17th
century because it was in the 17th
century that we started to move away
from the ventricles now how do we come
to do that
well how he discovered the circulation
of the blood some fifty years before
this experiment was performed alarmed
out to describe this experiment was one
which was conceived on what the
professor of anatomy at Oxford Thomas
Willis this was at the time of the
beginning of the rural society with with
Newton about the title occasion chair of
mathematics at Cambridge and what Thomas
Willis did together with that very
versatile character Christopher Wren
what he did was to conceive of a very
good test of the idea that it is the
psychic numa in the ventricles which is
then removed from the air which guilin
had put there in place 100 AD and goes
down the nerves to control the muscle
and the way to do it was to make sure
that the psychic Numa did contain
something from the blood because
Aristotle had said and garland had
emphasized the fact that in order to get
the Numa into the ventricles there
became psychic nema or heathered out
through the blood vessels so the blood
vessels must be continuous with the
ventricles so what they did was the
first experiment involving the
circulation of the blood they injected
using a thistle some Indian ink into the
carotid artery of a dog
and then after a while the ink of course
it passed through the blood screen
through the circulation that hardly had
just discovered they then opened up the
head and took some sections to see where
the ink was and of course it was meant
to be in the ventricles and it wasn't
there was no ink in the ventricles at
all the ink was in the cortex the walls
of the actual walls here of whoops on
the actual walls of the quarters I'll
get back their attention here now this
caused a lot of consternation
particularly with Descartes who was just
towards the end of his life because one
don't have it done was he had worked out
a plan of how the corporeal body relates
to the Platonic soul or platonic mind
and the way he had done this
Descartes had said when you look at the
body what you see is in the midline here
at the pineal gland it's not bifurcated
at all it's the only structure which is
not duplicated to some extent on each
side so it must be that part of the body
which takes the Corporal message and
gives it over to the psychic Numa in the
ventricles so what Descartes did was to
show us how it happens and here up here
is his drawing of a ventricle here is
the cyclic Numa in here and the
ventricle the fluid the ventricle here
is the pineal gland and here these
little three lines here indicate what
Aristotle said could not happen namely
here is the interaction between the
Corporal and the psychic Numa which
carried all these messages concerning
the psychic capacities and our
psychological abilities well there's a
Scarborough
that it was not the ventricles at all
really through the system of kilter
system that have been there since the
time of Bishop nemesis and this drawing
which is by Christopher Wren
of their discovery that it is this
cortical material which we really have
to pay attention to in relationship to
our psychological passages and therefore
the whole idea of the ventricles which
had been around then for some 1,400
years had to be discarded there was a
certain smugness I detect in some of you
in the audience is all around because
the Valu Dukas nature of the stories
which aren't actually telling they're
here I mean it's quite obvious that this
is the siren that is so as I as you will
see when I finish up here I think to
some extent we never Skype the paradigms
that we're working and even in
contemporary times in which coffin
what's happened in this case the last
five thousand years because we're always
caught in a very limited scope of
knowledge about what's going on it
doesn't pay to be too proud
at once theories or even those which
appear to be experimentally verified as
people have argued for 1300 years with
respective of integrals the next
question about this cortical material
which we need in order to sustain our
psychological abilities is what composes
it and that really had to wait until the
German dye industry got going in the
early 19th century and the idea of a
university department was generated in
Germany again and they appear Lee added
with the dye industry and so we began to
see that there were ways of staining
tissue and one of the way sustaining
tissue showed up but the cortex the wall
of a ventricle actually contains cells
which are now called neurons and here's
one here with these lovely long
processes of doing it early another one
here and you can see the whole area is
covered with these cellular elements so
the coordinators might have with cells
our psychological capacities seem to be
dependent on the workings of pre example
these neurons now the brain the cortex
is a very loud sheet that goes over a
long wire these cells are only the order
of about 150th of a millimeter an extent
so how does one part here of a
communicate with this pathway or
anything like that what's going on well
if you look more carefully particularly
down here what you see is that there are
very long processes
diagrammatically shown here so here are
these near ones which I showed you in a
real stone in the last over hood and
here they are sending out processes
which we call axons a long long way over
the cortex there might come in and
another region the cortex of method
connection and in the introduction to my
diatribe this evening the fact that I've
been working for 55 years on something
which is a thousandth of a millimeter
wide there knowing the synapse is
something which excites me but obviously
doesn't excite some of you very much so
we have these connections going on and
we have to grow now to compose
nice this well if that's the [ __ ] what
does the brain actually look like what
does the cortex itself look like what
does we take a section through the brain
what do we see given that most of the
cortex is grey matter that is neurons
which we now call very matter and a lot
of it is not gray matter it's what we
call white matter which are these axons
connecting these nerves connecting a
part of the brain here let's say to a
part here or partly to part there and
you can see that here what I've got here
is a section going that way through the
brine and this grey stuff at the top
here is where all those neurons are okay
so what Christopher Wren sword is
drawing is just the surface there that
was what his ruling was all just the
surface but vast amount of the cortex
here all this white matter are just
those axons those processes connecting
one part here to another powerful
I don't cut so what's all this stuff
doing with respect to our psychological
abilities how can you actually nail it
down
which parts responsible for thinking
which pass to see which pass them for
hearing which pass for having an
emotional attitude to life of one kind
or another what's going on here it is
just over a hundred years ago that
what's going on a large part of this was
described for the first time here at the
aisle by one of the two greatest
neuroscientists of the 20th century
giving the silliman lectures here and
that was Sir Charles Scott Sherrington
and one Charenton did was to show you
some of his own work and also there's
some work here of his students one of
the two most famous being will the pin
field and what will the pin field and
some of the other students including
Shelton himself showed was that first of
all if you look at the cortex and you
stimulate the cords over the cortex here
then different kinds of things happen to
a human being
so pent he'll when he was proving the
Brian for the region the brain that
would give rise to tremors in a patient
with epilepsy it wasn't allowed to take
any little person off the street open up
this
calendars experiments had to be some
neurological dices or even doing them he
was actually priming the burn and
stimulating it electrically try and find
the region where this person would
suddenly give a large jerk indicating
that this was a sensitive region if you
like for giving rise to epilepsy but in
the course of these experiments he made
a number of experimental discoveries one
was that when he stimulated out here the
back of the brain just here the person's
all visual changes not auditory ones no
changes in mood changes in thinking but
there would be changes in the visual
field time to the visual field would
suddenly get very bright or another part
would get very dark well suddenly a
strike would appear and another part of
the visual field
if you stimulated anywhere else that
never happened if you stimulated down
here which is just along the edge here
temporal lobe the so-called superior
typical guard you stick right on here
the person heard sounds that could be
hissing sounds loud sounds not vision at
all but silence in fact they had one
patient a female patient who when he
stimulated certain region here actually
she was elderly later that are you
through she actually heard a Beethoven
symphony was an arroyo symphony she said
it was a fantastic performance which had
last heard when she was 16 and Penfield
thought that was a lot of nonsense and
he went check that out of the Toronto
Town Hall infield being a Canadian and
working then in the Montreal clinic he
went to the Toronto Town Hall and found
the records for the particular concert
this woman had attended and lo and
behold there was the Eroica symphony so
this was to do with certainly audition
then when he came up here those dots are
all way along there he found he could
get movements of lives and I know the
face from Isis movements of that card
and then when he stimulated just behind
there he was able to get effects where
the patient said they had tingles and
their fingers was if there parts of his
skin were actually actively
why these are very interesting
observations with respect to our
perception capacitors because it
suggested that vision at least was
associated with a particular part of the
quarters something which was amplified a
great deal
five years after Sheraton gave his
lectures here at Yale during the first
world war the hundredth anniversary of
which we are commemorated next year
because of the enormous number of
shrapnel wounds on the Western Front
taking bits of the cortex out and you're
all just just like at the same time as
Galen acted on the gladiators they went
grab these persons that had these
terrible shrapnel wounds checked out
what had happened to their behavior and
found out they couldn't see so vision
was very well consolidated has been
associated with this part here the
interesting question is what about
nearly 80% of the cortex indicated here
which pin field couldn't get anything
not the vision hearing behavior of any
kind muscle movement anything at all
well as
Charenton pointed out in his lectures
here hundred years ago this is what
we've done he said we know that down
here is the temporal lobe associated in
this part here with word issue and we
know over here and concern with vision
we're now over here along here concerned
with something to do with skin and
feeling and we know as indicated the red
here something to do with movement but
we don't know what all this is about
well some of you will be aware that we
do other things besides see the world we
do other things than perception we do
other things than move our limbs we
actually some of us think and we
remember and we do things like that so
maybe some of this has got to do with
that and so maybe we could find here and
color it in a different color for
thinking that and for a large part of
the 20th century that was thought to be
the thinking get up here a navy up here
we might find the emotional bit
up here we might be able to
compartmentalize it further probably one
of the great breakthroughs in trying to
sort out what's going on here in the
hearing here at least technically a
great breakthrough was the invention by
Sheraton as he indicated here when he
came to Yarra from Oxford to give his
lectures the invention by Sheraton of
what we would now called non-invasive
imaging of the Brian where we can record
the activity of neurons without he
actually happened to break up the bride
into different bits and pieces and they
did that was to use this device this is
what I call for the cognoscenti in the
audience the reasonably modern
functional magnetic resonance imaging
machine and what he what shanton thought
together with a colleague of his was
professor of pathology he thought maybe
this changes on the surface of the brain
here that was a monkey not a human being
when the monkey does something maybe we
can detect something because they
thought that if they just look down and
for example stimulate there's a nerve
here to do with muscle then when they
went to the part of the brain up here
whoops
put them into the part of the Brian
group them coming through where they
went at the part of the brain here which
when was stimulated move muscle then
maybe when you move your muscle
voluntarily then there would be neural
activity here and since neurons probably
need some form of nutrient which even
the Egyptians realized was the case not
neurons in their case but the bodies
made it nutrient then the only thing
that could supply that would be blood
flow so maybe there would be a change in
blood flow either indicating that
neurons were active because when they
become active they need more nutrient
the nutrient comes from the blood
vessels and the blood vessels you have
to therefore increase flow and therefore
that to increase volume too so if we
could give a measure of the volume of
blood vessel changes here somewhere we
would have an indirect measure of neural
activity we would have to stimulate we
could just watch
animal in this case move its arm our
then-record up here the changes in the
blood vessels which would indicate to us
that they'd been some neuronal activity
and the device which he used to do that
is here
it's an upturned flask placed on the
surface of the cortex and it's got this
end the flask broken off and it's full
of fluid up to about living room and all
he did was to for example stimulate a
nerve which goes to a muscle here and
then see whether in fact there was a
change in blood flow here because the
blood vessels had increase in diameter
the fluid then moves up the tube
indicated this is a change in volume
therefore a change in neural activity
now the basis that much of the imaging
that goes on these days that you read
the new times of Letran is that concept
that blood flow blood changes of some
kind are related to neural activity we
don't have to open up the skull like
that anymore
but it's the same concept that is blood
flow in some form or other constituent
of blood which is changing related to
neural activity therefore we measure the
blood flow then we will get a handle on
that neural activity all right so he did
the experiment you've got a huge change
in that flow when you stimulate the
nerves which control muscles so he said
wow this is the wider Joe brink back
home to Oxford having given any Sillman
lectures what if we use this technique
now what does it tell us about these
large swathe here which we've got no
hands on yet at certainly after the time
which are described it of any activity
as pinky Oh couldn't find anything these
electrodes that's for sure well let me
give you an example of what we now find
in the last few years what I'm showing
you here is a lot of dots of different
colors and this particular experiment
what happened was that the patient here
was asked to distinguish the names on a
script on the screen of a number of
items its I was an apple an orange a
stick etc and just remembered for a few
seconds ten seconds or 20 seconds the
image on the screen was diagnosed I mean
the next thing would be actual shapes an
apple an orange
appear stick a book what had it I just
remember the shunt rectangle a long
island and then finally another
projection
how many items there three or six or
twelve the items taken away from the
screen you give in 20 seconds to keep in
memory what it was that you're asked how
many you say 20 or you make it wrong
number six whatever and when you do
those and you do the upturn flask
returning then the regions and activity
i with the brian cue infinitely by those
three sorts of activities are indicated
you see each of these little dots here
indicates a region which is active now
you can see there's a bit of a cluster
bit and the yellow dots are clustered
the red ones to bring out the fact that
cluster them covered difficulty black
ones difficult here and so on and we can
just give you here the center of the
clusters so here is the red cluster for
the center there and so on so these here
now are the Centers of the clusters now
what it turns out is that when you look
at the collection of items and you ask
to remember them in terms of their shunt
then this region here the brain is very
active this region is not directive here
this region here is less active this
region I had here is quite active and so
on and so forth when you're asked to
remember not the names of the objects or
the show but the number of objects all
vice versa this shape then you get the
same clusters been act we've been in a
different kind of quantitative activity
so instead of this being the highest
region activity it's now the lowest and
regional activity and instead of this
one being an intermediate level activity
it's now the highest level activity what
am I sign here what I'm saying is that
those regions which Penfield
couldn't get anything out all seem to
have a very distributed representation
I'll I'll use that word very advisedly
representation of your capacity and
memory to retain things on the basis of
them either they especially a little
kanai's numbers organize or in terms of
the actual names of the objects there is
no as the birth census community there
is no sight equivalent to the great
perception sites of or dishing and of
appearing I should say and the vision
won't have it there's not just a site
here the memory over a short term it's
it seems to be distributed over those
regions of cortex which Penfield was
unable to get anything out of when he
electrically stimulated it now for those
of you are not amongst the cognoscenti
and that I'm still caught in some kind
of interest in this topic I'm not going
to bore you by going through many other
examples of this kind of distributed
activity except to emphasize that it
isn't in a particular part of the brain
it tends to be all over the place if you
like not quite as perverse then my final
example as this farmers really I think
brings home the case here are different
sites both in the midline of the brain
and over the surface of the brain here
from which recordings of mine when
someone was looking at a screen and
asked to distinguish between the fact
that there were numbers on the screen
versus whether in fact there was
alphabet on the screen was simple as
that
numbers are out and it pushed the red
button on its numbers push the green
button in its outfitter and when they
did that each of these recordings was
made at different sites besides a number
B your public counts even but this
number 12 here goes to the number 12
there and so on and so forth so the
point is that at every time you get one
of these signals like that there the
subject was asked to make this
distinction between a number or a letter
of the alphabet then nothing at all then
they're asked to make a distinction
again
they're not in a tool and then so on so
this is here a sequence of five such
distinctions between a number or a
letter of the alphabet and you can see
this is a very regular kind of increase
in amplitude if you like a blood flow
indicated increase of neural activity
and that part of the bar but in this
part of the brain the activity goes in
the opposite direction
that could be is not getting bigger here
it's getting less and this part of the
brain
it's neither getting bigger nor getting
less it's going up then during the
actual distinction between alphabet or
numbers it's going down and then when
you're completing the task it goes up
again now if you proceed to determine
where all these are coming from over the
surface of the Brian what you can do is
you can color them all in so here is
each of those signals I've showed you
but they're they've been given different
colors this one went down this one went
up this one went down and so on and so
forth and if you distribute those colors
over the brain to see when the purse was
making these distinctions what parts of
the brain are involved you can see that
everything is involved
everything is colored over the whole
cortex those different signals each of
which was distinguished for a different
color is coming out in different regions
so what I'm doing is emphasizing a great
deal and perhaps over emphasizing the
fact that this is not all collected in
one part of the brain and furthermore
the signals are very weird shapes of one
kind or another which we haven't got any
public knowledge of the depression as to
where and why we have these different
signals and I might add just to
emphasize why you should be slightly
skeptical about the New York Times even
though it's a wonderful newspaper and
that is that most researchers throw away
a lot of this data they say I only like
the big signals the little signals well
you know the Lord didn't make this
cortex to have little signals he only
wanted big C's or she only wanted big
signals so well I only keep the big
signals or others say look you couldn't
possibly have the signals that go down
will any type the ones that go up and so
on and so forth there are now 36,800
research papers on this topic and many
of them just to build up your skepticism
work on the basis that I only like big
seizures or they work on the basis that
we should only have signals of a certain
shape and so on and so forth
that is a very sad I think story and I
think it's a story very akin and I hope
it doesn't go as long as long as
thirteen hundred years the ventricular
doctrine but you never know it's making
a lot of money and the ventricular
doctrine probably made doctors a lot of
money also oh how come the cortex that
Penfield couldn't get anything out of
how come it's all that giveaway were the
place well we now have teased out that
white matter I showed you underneath the
top of the cortex that white matter of
our axons or nerves connect in one part
to another and it's magnificent and I'll
just give you an inkling of it here this
is a human brain this is not a dead
person you can now do this with imaging
techniques and here is a tract of axons
there's thousands of them in there of
nerves connecting the front part that's
called the cingulum to the back part of
the brain and here's all sorts of other
major nerves which constitute that what
mass I showed you in that section
through the brain so there's this
massive interconnectedness between one
part of the brain of another and
therefore it's not at all surprising
that when we go to the more complex
parts of our psychological abilities
remembering every extensive period of
time let alone getting into the area of
thinking or as Bob Sherman and I have
been talking about recently of falling
in love or something of that aspect of
our activity little I'm getting into
that gyeom we are in a very complex
arrangement of cortical activity and we
haven't sorted any of it out by a long
shot one of the most disturbing aspects
of our work which really requires our
startle dickin stands did has been so
for 65 years we really need Aristotle
back and that is this word repres
tosia it is right throughout the
neuroscientific literature now it makes
no sense because it's totally Cartesian
because when I was on Saturday at the
Met looking at Suzanne's still lives
here was the apples and oranges on the
table okay and so I'm looking at these
apples and oranges Suzanne painted this
it's a representation of apples and
oranges who is it a representation of
apples and oranges for it's for me it's
for me a patron of the arms looking at
the apples and oranges that brings up
the point is who is this representation
of these signals up here who is it for
who's looking down and saying ah there
it is
he can distinguish between their behalf
abettor numbers or whatever the case
might be the word representation has led
us into this game of kind of gradually
working our way through the Cartesian
philosophy to a point where were almost
evaporating ourselves because we don't
know where we're going at all because
clearly there's no little a monkey on us
up there at all sitting down watching
the TV set which is the stream of our
lives experiences as expressed in our
psychological powers
so to summarize where have we come in
the hundred years and Charenton stood in
Yale and gave is taught well this is
what he gave us
I'm reduce again as I've already
emphasized and probably have here is the
motor cortex and the auditory cortex and
the visual cortex and so on what I'm
indicating to is that once we get out of
these kinds of straightforward
perception inputs if you like an hour
motor out them once we've got out of
that area and we're in this game here
then we have been in real trouble and
although there are claims and
counterclaims present all over the place
and there's thousands of papers just as
there probably were over the 13 hundred
years of the ventricular document we are
of that particular idea we are in
trouble what we are claiming a present
as compared to Sheridan as this
Sheratons title of his lectures was the
integrative nature of the nervous system
and he published a book which was the
summary of his a monograph summarizing
in our lectures which was called just
that the integrative nature of the
nervous system
what Charenton had showed was our Mabel
to be able to move their reflexes our
capacity even Dewalt could all be worked
out in terms of integration of the
nerves in the spinal cord not involving
the head at all that was a remarkable
friend so in a hundred years since then
with all this here what have we got well
what we have got is that certainly
there's some kind of integration going
on but it isn't straightforward at all
it involves multiple dynamic activities
between one part of another altering
within the time that we are carrying out
or participating in the behavior
associated with a psychological act so
these powers of ours which I mentioned
in my introduction a perception and
voluntary movement of memory under the
ethic of the affections and their
sensations all of these powers I clearly
have got something to do with this
system up here that we know a little bit
about what's involved up there but we
are really at the beginning of a very
long journey and it's getting tougher as
we go on thank you very much
you